l'amour n'a pas d'âge et si ce vieil
adage avait déjà fait ses preuves si le
premier amour reste inoubliable ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux à avoir décidé
de vivre une seconde fois le grand amour
Marc Lavoine Sophie Marceau ou encore
Christine Bravo qui s'est tout juste
remarié cet été encore on peut aussi
choisir de se laisser une seconde chance
récemment ce sont les animateurs William
Leymergie et Sophie Davant qui a 59 et
75 ans semble avoir décidé de revivre à
fond leur jeunesse et pour ces stars peu
importe l'orage mais ma plus de 50 ans
il pense qu'il est encore possible de
raviver la flamme et de vivre une
nouvelle idylamoureuse une tendance qui
ne touche pas que les célébrités puisque
même sur Internet les seniors ont le
droit à leur site de rencontre j'en ai
pratiqué depuis quelques années dès
intéressante d'autres un peu moins
certains qu'il faut payer 38% des
célibataires de plus de 50 ans aurait
d'ailleurs déjà cherché l'amour à
travers ses plateformes faire en
essayant que on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
bonne nouvelle et de rencontrer
quelqu'un de très bien quoi alors
peut-on réellement retrouver l'amour
passer 50 ans
et on dira aussi un monde sur un gros
pot parce que là moi ça c'est le début
c'est peut-être la France voir parler
donc avec nous également Catherine
Solano qui est sexologue merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous beaucoup de questions
helloïse des Montiers agence de
rencontre pour seniors
je vous avais déjà reçu l'année dernière
depuis on se changeait Instagram on peut
le dire ou pas voilà très bien alors
d'abord on va dire quand même que vous
étiez vous étiez dans Plus Belle La Vie
Céline Raymond pendant près de toutes
les saisons et justement je vais le dire
puisque vous avez tourné la dernière
séquence qui seront diffusées en
novembre prochain le dernier prime
s'appelait sept mariage et pas
l'enterrement et ouais j'ai toutes les
infos et voilà et dans ce prime de
nombreux acteurs de l'origine qui seront
et qui seront de retour alors c'est que
deux questions parce qu'il me faut un
petit scoop c'est mettre saisons il faut
que je lance un petit peu faut que je
sois repris un petit peu partout vous
comprenez parce que moi les gens s'en
foutent ils veulent les infos je vais
essayer de vous aider va-t-elle se
marier dans le dernier épisode je peux
pas vous aider
comment ça s'est passé le dernier jour
de tournage mais je sais pas on l'a pas
encore fait mais il va bien se passer
non je parle pas terminé
[Rires]
ridicule bon en tous les cas vous vous
mariez dans le dernier épisode on va
dire ça
fait plaisir à tout le monde et c'est
bien alors
Rebecca non mais je veux dire la vérité
j'ai regardé un petit peu les débuts de
saison et après j'ai un petit peu lâché
parce que boulot boulot
alors Rebecca et bien on a appris ça il
y a pas très très longtemps donc d'abord
vous avez même pas 50 ans de ce que j'ai
dit mais vous avez rencontré l'amour il
y a pas longtemps oui mais quand mais il
y a un peu plus d'un an quand
l'âge
mais il y a un peu plus d'un an et en
fait j'étais une célibataire endurcie
j'avais absolument pas envie de
rencontrer quelqu'un
pourquoi vous voulez plus rencontrer
quelqu'un bah parce que j'avais pas
envie que honnêtement le célibat mal
allait vachement bien et que je j'avais
plus envie j'avais pas envie d'être déçu
j'avais pas envie de investir j'étais
avec ma fille j'étais une maman comblée
j'allais très bien et j'avais pas du
tout prévu que quelqu'un vienne dans ma
vie et bouleverse complètement ma vie en
fait et cette personne qui est arrivée
dans votre vie justement là c'est
sérieux mes questions est-ce que non
parce que je rigole tout le temps mais
est-ce que justement quand on aime une
deuxième ou une troisième fois peu
importe à 50 ans non mais est-ce que 50
ans on aime de la même manière est-ce
qu'on a un coup de foudre est-ce que
c'est beaucoup plus calme est-ce que
c'est lent est-ce que tu n'aimes
[Musique]
le lit grince ah mais c'est pas calme
non mais le coeur comment on dit bien
sûr le cœur dans le ventre 49 ans non
parce qu'on a tendance à dire que quand
on est plus vieux c'est une amitié
amicale c'est plus doux c'est plus
moi je pense que l'amour n'a pas d'âge
et je vous entendais tout à l'heure
parler en temps il fait chaud j'ai plus
de libido moi je ne suis pas d'accord je
pense que plus on vieillit plus on a une
libido intéressante d'ailleurs même dans
les EHPAD dans les EHPAD il y a des
coups qui se forment et qui sont chauds
Isabelle enlève ton téléphone
je vais poser la question je vais poser
la question à Catherine parce qu'en plus
Catherine je vous dis la vérité moi j'ai
des gens dans ma famille et qui viennent
d'avoir 50 ans je vous dirais pas qui
serait fou et qui m'ont dit voilà je te
dis franchement avec mon mari c'est plus
compliqué je transpire un peu plus j'ai
moins de libido je prends un peu plus de
poids c'est horrible ce cap de de la
ménopause j'ai moins d'envie j'ai moins
de et j'ai plus d'ambis sexuel est-ce
que ça va revenir je suis pas en train
de rêver c'est ce qu'elle me dise une
ordonnance
arrive parce que à la ménopause en fait
les femmes ont une chute d'hormones des
estrogènes et c'est ce qui donne le pic
de libido au moment de l'ovulation et il
y en a plus après la ménopause mais il y
a beaucoup de femmes qui au contraire
disent je suis libéré de la
contraception parce oui la contraception
souvent ça peut être Isa
mais est-ce que c'est vous êtes en train
de me dire que parfois il y a ou ou ce
que je me disent d'autres femmes c'est
du coup c'est plus lent pendant un petit
moment il y a 55 ça revient il faut
passer un petit peu ça revient tout de
suite parce que j'ai pas 50 alors
peut-être qu'il me reste encore un an
avant que ça soit l'enfer vous vous
doutez bien que jamais j'aurais l'un des
licatesse de vous demander si vous êtes
ménopausées
mais il y a aucune indélébration sinon
je serais pas venu sur ce plateau parce
que je vous connais un petit peu ben je
crois que je suis périmé ah c'est
plusieurs fois
andropause moi je suis là je pense je
vais en parler moi ça peut arriver
jusqu'à 30 ans d'avoir moins de libido
exactement
la personne qu'elle adore
que Daniel Moreau
ou retrouver l'amour je pense que c'est
deux choses différentes aussi absolument
c'est ça là n'empêche pas l'autre c'est
vrai on n'a pas forcément envie de
retrouver l'amour et là vous parliez du
poids aussi personne que j'ai pris du
poids ça joue énormément sur les femmes
une femme qui se dit maintenant j'ai 50
ans je me sens moche j'ai pris des kilos
et cetera elle a pas de libido si elles
se sont belles qu'elle se pomponne à 70
ans il y a des femmes qui sont très
madame sauf que Madame pardon mais c'est
médical que ce soit pour les garçons
pour les femmes quand on a une baisse
d'hormones forcément on a aussi moins
d'énergie on a aussi moins d'envies
sexuelle c'est médical oui mais chez les
hommes qui ont une andropause il y a une
baisse de testostérone donc ils ont une
baisse de libido ceux qui passent par
l'andropause mais c'est pas tous les
hommes alors que chez les femmes il y a
pas du tout de suite
pardon on va en parler mais c'est très
important
quand on a moins de libido on ne trouve
pas nécessairement l'amour on a
peut-être pas envie mais en fait moi je
pense que si on a envie de partager sa
vie avec quelqu'un être accompagnée
chaque jour chaque soir sauf que Hugo
mais c'est le cas de la personne dont je
parlais j'ai vu c'est ma famille je m'en
fous mais quand ce sont deux personnes
qui ont le même âge et que le mec lui il
est encore en pleine bout et qu'il
aimerait bien faire ça deux fois par
semaine et que toi tu n'as plus libido
bien sûr que tu es inquiète t'inquiète
que ton mari aille voir ailleurs parce
que tu simules un peu pardon c'est
important
c'est très bien et pourtant ils ont un
gros décalage apparemment
mais tu mélanges un peu tout parce que
là tu parles d'un couple qui peut par
exemple avoir une certaine longévité et
donc peut-être que ça peut estomper les
désirs etc mais il y a pas d'âge je veux
dire moi par exemple j'ai une anecdote
avec Daniel Evenou qui a plus de 80 ans
un jour elle m'a c'est lui duranda
tu vois ce que je veux dire
alors je le dis alors j'ai trouvé ça
beau j'ai trouvé voilà une nana qui
assume à son âge ses désirs c'est oui
mais c'est pas pareil Daniel Daniel
c'est une meuf qui est passionnée par
les cases et qui passe tous les jours
devant une Ferrari
c'est que quelque soit l'âge en début de
relation il y a beaucoup de libido voilà
que ça soit à 20 à 15 à 20 à 30 à 40 à
70 la libido est beaucoup plus élevé au
début d'une relation en France de de
rapports sexuels par semaine alors
justement
et après 55 ans ça baisse un peu à 5 par
mois
après 55 ans
qui est très intéressant
je m'intéresse à vous madame parce
qu'évidemment j'aimerais bien savoir un
peu de temps les femmes
de ce qu'on leur posait une question
alors sexuelle dans l'année qui vient de
s'écouler il y en a 50 % qui disait non
alors actuelle c'est une sur 10 ça a
énormément changé on dit que la
libération sexuelle ça surtout changé la
durée de vie de la vie sexuelle en fait
ça grâce à Madame du coup peut-être
grâce à Madame alors c'est quoi c'est
quoi Héloïse ce site donc qui vient vous
voir et pourquoi
merci pour les marques
et en fait pour la petite histoire c'est
qu'il y a 5 ans on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait une multitude
d'applications de rencontres une seule
cible les jeunes les jeunes les jeunes
et là est-ce que quelqu'un sait combien
il y a de célibataires en France un
chiffre
[Musique]
18 j'irai un peu plus moi peut-être 25
pas mal
25 millions mais non célibataire en
France combien de célibataires ont plus
de 50 ans
donc aujourd'hui il y a 9 millions
d'hommes et femmes de plus de 50 ans qui
ont célibataire
en fait on crée des jours pour des
jeunes il y a des personnes c'est vrai
son 9 millions ils intéressent personne
invisibles votre sexualité le fait de
tomber amoureux jamais ça ne nous
intéresse pas je veux pas voir je veux
pas savoir donc là on commence à
regarder et on se dit mais en réalité
pourquoi créer une app dédiée c'est vrai
en fait on pourrait se dire ils vont sur
d'autres marques sans densité et en fait
on se rend compte très vite qu'ils nous
disent deux choses hein j'ai pas très
envie d'aller sur une app pour y croiser
mon fils et ses potes c'est clair merci
bien sûr
et deuxièmement la réalité c'est que moi
ma vie
matrimoniale familiale je l'ai
construite là j'ai envie d'autre chose
est-ce que j'ai envie c'est de trouver
quelqu'un pour m'éclater pour partager
des centres d'intérêt oui parce que là
pardon mais c'est le monde de Oui-Oui
vous racontez parce que la vraie vie
vous voulez que je voulais dire aussi
c'est qu'en général dans la vraie vie
les dieux veulent pas être les vieux les
personnes pardon je parle de ça parce
que je connais les personnes handicapées
peuvent battent avec des personnes
handicapées les personnes de petite
taille veulent pas de personnes et un
mec souvent ils cherchent une meuf qui a
25 ans de moins et quand tu es seule et
que tu as 55 t'as pas envie de te mettre
sur un site de seigneur tu vas en boîte
de nuit tu fais le vieux beau tu fais
comme moi tu fais une teinture et puis
tu essaies
c'est vrai
Rebecca je peux vous demander déjà je
vous le dis c'est tellement sincère pour
moi vous êtes une des plus jolies femmes
que je connaisse vous êtes à la moi
j'adore les blancs mais vous êtes et toi
non vous êtes magnifique vraiment mais
est-ce que vous pouvez la question c'est
quoi l'âge de votre mari on a 100 ans à
nous deux
et vous auriez souhaité un plus jeune ou
est-ce que
mais il en aurait eu 45 il en aurait eu
c'était pareil et c'est lui et
personnage n'a rien que le physique on
le voit et qu'on avait jamais été aussi
heureuse comment vous n'avez jamais été
aussi heureuse c'est difficile de dire
ça en tous les cas j'ai jamais été aussi
pleinement amoureuse et aussi sereine
dans ma vie
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'est pas plus dans l'état
d'esprit des gens aujourd'hui de se dire
par exemple moi bon moi mon père a
décidé à très longtemps ma mère a 70 ans
quoi elle est célibataire et moi j'ai
plus la sensation que les les gens par
exemple prendre un exemple de maman elle
va vouloir que je dis ça mais on a
l'impression que les gens ils se disent
moi pour moi c'est trop tard je rentre
pas dans cette case c'est fini c'était
avant je peux pas faire ma vie c'est ça
maman moi je te coupe j'aimerais qu'elle
le retrouve mais c'est très mignon
va te défoncer la mienne aussi parce que
moi je vais dire un truc c'est que ma
maman elle a 83 ans et qu'à 77 ans elle
est tombée folle à moi
j'ai vu ma maman je vais me faire tuer
mais comme une gamine en même temps je
suis tombée amoureuse
en ce moment
la réalité c'est qu'en fait on s'intit
interdit parce que pendant des années on
s'est dit c'est un truc de jeunes et
puis de quoi je vais avoir l'air et
qu'est-ce que la voisine va raconter et
qu'est-ce que ma belle-sœur va venir de
dire donc en fait nous notre but en 5 en
5 ans aujourd'hui on a 2 millions et
demi d'inscrits moi mon seul but en
venant ici c'est dire c'est normal c'est
tout ce que je souhaite exactement ce
genre de plus de 50 ans
au contraire arrêtez les barrières qu'on
se met c'est les barrières qu'on se met
à soi-même et
je pose ma question parce que j'ai
oublié tu me connais moi
tu es magnifique bouge pas bouge pas
tout le temps moi c'est le sujet me
passionne mais toi aussi tu vas pouvoir
juste me poser des questions est-ce que
à 60 ans les amours en tout cas sur ce
site dure à peu près ça dure plus
longtemps peut-être ou est-ce qu'il y a
aussi pardon des amours d'un soir des
des plans cul enfin c'est c'est quoi la
suite des fantasmes sur des gens qui
n'ont pas notre âge juste parce que ça
nous fait délirer comme on projette des
fantasmes sur des gens qui ont 20 ans en
fait les histoires d'amour sont toutes
différentes il y a des gens il y a des
gens ils nous parlent ils me disent
alors moi je te préviens jamais je
vivrai avec lui hein c'est bon j'ai eu
un mec dans ma vie pendant 40 ans à la
maison alors là faudra pas me les
refaire deux ans après on va on se marie
vous êtes en couple moi je suis en
couple marié trois enfants un chien donc
moi je suis dans la catégorie
alors attention Isabelle plan cul dans
les maisons de retraite
de mon mari était marié pendant
plusieurs décennies au même homme très
catholique très croyante il est mort
elle en a eu 5 en disant après
et donc c'est voilà et c'est un monsieur
de 90 ans qui a trouvé l'amour en maison
de retraite là avec une presque
centenaire et qui me racontait cette
histoire
parce que je sais alors je sais Isabelle
et on l'embrasse très fort que ton mari
Alain et et souffrant est malade et
vraiment avant que ce soit un petit peu
le cas il y a quelques années tu
arrêtais pas de dire en TPMP pour rire à
tous les samedis tous les dimanches
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous aviez une
sexualité non mais est-ce que non c'est
pas pour rire est-ce que c'est vrai vous
avez une sexualité est-ce que c'était
même mieux qu'avant quand tu étais plus
jeune il me parle comme si j'avais 4 ans
non mais
là mais si la vérité Isabelle quand tu
as dit que tu faisais l'amour deux fois
par semaine c'est plus que moi alors
forcément
et jusqu'à jusqu'à son hospitalisation
c'est encore le cas à l'hosto non mais
bien sûr là j'ai besoin
de ces deux personnes âgées qu'on vient
tous ensemble il y a très drôle
mais pourquoi vous voulez divorcer
maintenant je comprends pas vous venez
de me dire que vous voulez divorcer du
bah oui on peut divorcé mais pourquoi
vous voulez divorcer maintenant presque
100 ans moi je m'attendais que les
enfants soient morts
cette année ils offrent des blagues
drôles
alors
Catherine et après on ira de ce côté là
parce que c'est bon je voulais dire
quelque chose de très important vous
avez parlé des femmes qui disent ben moi
j'en ai marre j'ai eu un homme pendant
40 ans je n'en veux plus j'étais son
esclave je ressens ça tous les jours
mais on parle pas beaucoup des hommes
qui ne veulent pas se remettre en couple
parce qu'ils ont peur d'avoir un
problème d'érection c'est moi je suis
tout le temps en train
[Applaudissements]
sans arrêt je dis aux hommes mais vous
pouvez prendre du Viagra ou un autre
médicament de cette famille je leur dis
quand
des lunettes parce qu'on voit moins bien
on voit jamais rester avec une dent au
moins on se dit bah je mets un implant
ou on met un appareil auditif je vois
pas pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
il faut profiter de ce que la vie nous
donne si on avance en âge et qu'on peut
pas profiter de la vie c'est quand même
dommage mais alors on parle des hommes 2
secondes j'espère que votre va très bien
non je me sens pas inquiet je dis la
vérité quand on a une petite moi j'ai un
très bon ami
[Applaudissements]
forcément même au sport ils sont en
compte et tout il y a un peu moins de
testostérone il récupère un peu moins
bien il est à moi envie de sexe il
reconnaît la moins envie parfois il
force un petit peu et parfois il fait
même des trucs que parfois peuvent faire
des femmes j'imaginais peut-être avant
c'est que de temps en temps non mais tu
fais pour faire plaisir enfin tu auras
préféré ma petite série et vous allez me
dire ce que vous voulez tout ça c'est
pas que dans la tête qu'est-ce qu'on
fait il faut voir un médecin pour donner
plus de testostérone tout ça c'est pas
que dans la tête madame il y a des
réalités médicales il sait moins pour ce
garçon
souvent si vous voulez quand ça marche
un peu moins bien par exemple quand un
homme a un problème d'érection
comme ça il a peur que ça fonctionne pas
donc il évite les rapports sexuels il
les espaces il a moins d'envie donc
souvent le premier traitement quand on a
pas suffisamment d'envie si les
infections sont un peu moyennes et bien
on prend un traitement on donne un
traitement et souvent parlant libido
alors que ça n'agit pas sur la libido
mais s'agit sur le manque et surtout à
tout à l'heure pour cet ami
alors les filles et juste avant les les
le groupe des chaudasses là pas vous
bien sûr réfeccable
non mais je sens que je peux vous poser
des questions très sincères j'imagine
que ça dépend de la personne mais à
personne égale parce que certainement
que la première fois que vous êtes tombé
amoureuse vous étiez amoureuse avec la
même sincérité est-ce que c'est vous
avez plus de plaisir à faire l'amour à
50 ans qu'on en a 30 alors je vais vous
dire un truc j'ai plus de plaisir à
faire l'amour à 50 enfin à 49 ans bien
sûr mais pas parce que j'ai 49 ans parce
que c'est lui c'est bien sûr
la dernière fois j'étais triste là je te
je vais mieux c'est vrai alors Ludivine
Mathieu parler de problèmes érectiliens
il y a quelques instants il y a des
c'est vrai qu'il y a pardon si je te
dérange maintenant
et c'est vrai que pour les hommes il y a
beaucoup d'options donc les petites
pilules bleues et qu'on sort et par
exemple une femme mais c'est vraiment
pas moi pour le coup je suis pas dans le
cas de Mathieu mais pour les amis c'est
pas c'est un ami ça va ouais c'est un
ami
mais pour les femmes il existe quoi la
voisine quand on attend
le creux de la botte
je peux vous dire déjà détrompez-vous
c'est pas que les femmes après la
ménopause qui ont des difficultés il y a
30% des femmes à peu près de jeunes qui
ont des problèmes de sécheresse vaginale
et dans ces cas là on donne des idées ou
des lubrifiants des choses et chez les
hommes jeunes aussi on a beaucoup de
problèmes des régions
42 ans depuis 5 ans mais aussi
grave faut pas oui c'est sûr que si on
fait rien on a une super vie mais on
s'emmerde pardon mais
Ludivine est beau des bottes très jamais
Ludivine dont tu as 42 43 ans
non mais si tu veux bah tu sais quoi
elle était ménopause à 44 ma question
c'est est-ce que est-ce que ça vous fait
peur
alors c'est pas que ce soit une hantise
parce que j'avoue que voilà je fais tout
pour essayer de vieillir sans trop de
c'est vrai sans qui est trop dégâts mais
j'ai peur parce que vous voyez j'ai tout
le temps ventilateur j'ai tout le temps
sauf que ça fait déjà que j'ai tout le
temps chaud donc je suis peut-être entré
ménopause depuis mes 35 ans
faut pas non plus se mettre une pression
pas possible j'ai l'impression que là on
est tous en train de parler de ne parler
non mais de ne parler que du sexe
exactement
il y a des moments il y a des moments où
comme tout le monde j'ai j'ai pas de
désir c'est comme ça mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'à un moment un couple il y
a si on passe toute notre vie avec
quelqu'un il y a des moments où on doit
être enfin réactifs des moments
faut que je prenne du viagra faut que je
prenne des heures en mode il y a un
moment ça va nous faire devenir
après qu'on a un dernier mot avec avec
Madame et juste pour rassurer quelqu'un
je fais les deux je fais les 30 derniers
et les Quincas c'est souvent au lit et
je m'éclate maintenant mais c'est très
intéressant c'est pour vous rassurer
chez vous et non mais je m'éclate plus
au lit avec les hommes de 50 ans qu'avec
ceux de 30 voilà il a raison de le dire
il y a une alchimie qui est là ils ont
dû savoir faire ils ont dû respect c'est
pas juste c'est pas dans les films on a
30 ans et on imite il y a quelque chose
moi j'aimerais Catherine que vous
donniez que vous donniez il nous reste
30 secondes que vous donniez ah voilà un
espoir parce qu'on rigole beaucoup mais
c'est c'est très important moi j'ai
adoré ce sujet ce plateau l'espoir final
deux fois par jour viagra deux fois par
jour non non par rapport ménopause que
je peux dire c'est que j'ai l'impression
que c'est les laboratoires qui se sont
dit on va transformer la ménopause qui
est comme la puberté un épisode normal
de la vie en une maladie pour vendre
plein de médicaments à 50% de la
population
voilà c'est la première chose la
ménopause c'est naturel la plupart des
femmes la traverse bien si on peut avoir
besoin on reste quand même pas égal face
aux hommes d'accord
Isabelle Ayem 5 secondes
comme tu les aimes moi j'ai été
quelqu'un qui était plus âgé que moi ok
qui avait quand même 25 ans de plus que
moi et je peux t'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
de règle parce que ça libido était bien
plus présente que la mienne alors que
moi jeunes et lui plus âgé
comme quoi le problème c'est moi
merci à rebeccamponne d'avoir été avec
nous merci Éloïse merci et Madame